[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal de
tv 60 18 26 minutes pour faire le tour
de l'actualité locale voici les titres
et de ce mardi 15 octobre
chaque année un français produit en
moyenne 350 kg d'ordures ménagères
certains habitants se sont lancés dans
une démarche de réduction
un défi zéro déchet se déroule en ce
moment dans le centre et le sud des
yvelines reportage et un invité en
plateau
maïtena biraben et gad elmaleh comme
lecteur mille jeunes pour composer et
tester leur niveau d'orthographe la
dictée pour tout se déroulait samedi au
château de versailles
le thème cette année la citoyenneté et
puis le parcours du tour de france 2020
a été dévoilée ce matin ce n'est pas une
surprise la dernière étape partira des
yvelines mystère levé sur la ville
départ mantes-la-jolie et tous les
coureurs s'élanceront le 19 juillet mais
avant de développer ses titres visite au
sein de ce chantier le centre commercial
open sky doit ouvrira ses portes au
printemps 2020 à plaisir les travaux
sont lancés sur place depuis janvier
2010 est le site qui comprendra une
trentaine de commerces et un cinéma le
point avec nicolas landry c'est une
question de mois maintenant entre mars
et avril 2020 le centre commercial
opensky de plaisir va ouvrir ses portes
une trentaine d'enseignants sera
installé au sein de cette infrastructure
ici nous sommes dans la galerie
marchande dans cette ancienne belle
galerie qui sera couverte par une par
une toiture ans
une matière qu'on appelle le tf qui est
une matière qui à la fois protéger la
pluie mais permet la transparence
les premiers magasins sont en train
d'être livré aux preneurs c'est le cas
notamment de prat et marque la cellule
qui tout au fond vert - et donc qui
travaillent mais ce qui commence
maintenant si cette phase d'aménagement
pour les différents magasins
l'aménagement intérieur
alors que le reste du chantier est en
train lui d'être d'être complétée est
terminée des baies vitrées du marbre sur
les façades 200 personnes travaillent
actuellement sur le chantier d'un côté
une zone commerciale fermé et de l'autre
une partie ouverte sur l'extérieur juste
derrière moi se trouvera en ouverture un
escalier monumental qui descendra
jusqu'à la partie ouverte la partie
retail park du projet avec en bas un
petit un miroir d'eau autour duquel
s'articulera une zone de restauration on
voit la structure métallique est en
train d'être montés sur laquelle va
venir se positionner ce qu'on appelle la
vêture du bâtiment c'est à dire son
enveloppe extérieure ce qui sera
vraiment vu par
les utilisateurs qui arrivent par la
route
là vous êtes en train de faire le trajet
qui effectuera un véhicule en arrivant
sur ce site en empruntant les allées
pour aller vers les parkings souterrains
open sky va renforcer le dynamisme de la
zone commerciale plaisir les clayes sous
bois
à la clé plus de 300 emplois vont être
créés avec moi en plateau maria dias
muñoz bonsoir vous êtes chargé de
mission énergie et animations à la lèque
sky celle agence locale de l'énergie et
du climat avec vous on va parler du défi
zéro déchet qui a été lancé depuis un
mois déjà elle des familles du centre et
du sud yvelines
y participent pendant trois mois ils
vont peser leurs poubelles réorganiser
aussi leur mode de vie et de
consommation mathilde et demi est allé à
la rencontre de deux familles zéro
déchet à la verrière la voix de ce
reportage signée manon varaldo plus
carton ni de plastique dans la cuisine
zéro déchet de valérie et cyril qui se
sont lancés dans ce mode de vie depuis
trois ans il n'y a plus que des bocaux
des fruits et légumes et des boîtes en
verre qui contiennent des produits frais
on va en grande surface on va sur le
marché on va dans les magasins bio et on
y on amène nos beaux qu on amène aussi
des sacs
parce que beaucoup de bocaux ça peut
faire lourd à la fin dans le cabas donc
du coup on prend son procès sac à brac
des sacs en tissu des sacs en papier on
arrive ici et on les verse dans les
bocaux depuis un an la famille klein a
créé le collectif vers higuain pour
partager leurs recettes et astuces zéro
déchet pour changer leurs habitudes
cyril conseille d'y aller pas à pas faut
y aller petit à petit j'ai essayé de
faire un dosage essayé de changer de
dentifrice
je vais essayer de faire telle ou telle
chose dans la dans la cuisine où je vais
faire mes courses en vrac
c'était une lors de leurs premières
démarches ces deux c'est vraiment plus
dans la cuisine en étant 5 à la maison
cela peut paraître compliqué mais les
thomas qui sont membres du collectif
vers higuain ont déjà commencé à changer
leurs habitudes de consommation
typiquement on n'achète plus d'eau en
bouteille c'était une habitude qu'on
avait avant aujourd'hui on prend l'eau
du robinet on la met au dans des
récipients en verre donc recyclable
outils pour les mêmes mais nettoie ton
entend bien sûr on commence déjà aussi à
faire des produits d'entretien et dvd
produits cosmétiques nous mêmes avec des
recettes vraiment très simple morgane la
benjamine de la famille thomas est
conquise par le zéro déchet et le fait
maison
elle fabrique depuis peu ses savons avec
ses parents par exemple les champions
ont fait parce que quand tu vois le
plastique il ya autour
eh ben on étudie déjà et du plastique
donc faut pas trop en prendre
et quand tu les fais soi même déjà c'est
bien pentu partage des trucs par exemple
pas moi avec ma maman ou papa une prise
de conscience pour ces familles qui
s'investissent de plus en plus dans le
zéro déchet il ne ferons pas machine
arrière
viry green dont qui est partenaire de ce
défi zéro déchet comme plusieurs
associations yvelinoise l'opération a
débuté
maria dias muñoz depuis le 13 septembre
et se poursuit jusqu'au 1er décembre et
elle est organisée je le disais tout à
l'heure par la lex kyle agence locale de
l'énergie et du climat
qu'est ce que la lèque justement pour
ceux qui ne vous connaissent pas quelles
sont vos missions
alors là l'ex et c'est le référent local
sont trois essieux des sites line pour
toutes les questions
ce qui concerne la maîtrise de l'énergie
et du climat
on a principalement un rôle
d'accompagnement et des conseils auprès
des particuliers des collectivités du
grand public en général des écoles aussi
et et voilà en plein de cet
accompagnement on a on a le conseil
faire le conseiller info énergie où les
gens il peut ne se contacter pour toutes
les questions en lien avec un rénovation
énergétique économies énergies voilà je
veux changer ma chaudière
j'appelle la lèque pour avoir des
missions principales finalement sur
l'énergie là pourquoi proposer cette
opération qui concerne elle les déchets
ce défi zéro déchet alors réduire les
décès ça veut dire faire des économies
mais aussi et voilà donc oui c'est une
thématique de l'ademe il était toujours
présent dans le défi famille l'énergie
positif et il ya en fait c'est la
troisième édition
c'est l'année où on voit là on s'est
décidé à le faire
il ya un vrai lien entre gestion des
déchets et préservation de
l'environnement du climat oui oui tout à
fait et réduire les déchets ça veut dire
limiter la pollution
on va voir on va dignité ben voilà on va
réduire déjà la quantité de plastique et
présente aujourd'hui dindane et social
le sol toutes les particules existantes
on va aussi faire des économies
d'énergie et limiter les émissions des
gaz à effet de serre lignée
lle voilà au traitement des déchets la
transformation des matériaux
voilà il faut savoir qui et 3% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre sont
liées à ce pas ce traitement des déchets
et du coup les objectifs d'une telle
opération on a vu dans le reportage de
famille une qui est totalement initiés
et qui pratique depuis trois ans le zéro
déchet une qui si tout juste s'est donné
finalement les clés à ces personnes pour
aller vers une réduction des déchets sur
des défis oui dont les fils oui voilà en
effet le 10 sport le défi en fait il
l'est il ya deux de période en période
de référence où les lions ils vont pas
ils vont pas choisi ses habitudes et
ensuite il ya le reste c'est une période
de changement ils vont appliquer les
gestes qui vont apprendre enfin dans nos
défis il va voir une série d'animations
des ateliers des conférences aux écoutes
au long de ce défi l'heure de jeu voilà
il faut peser les déchets une fois par
semaine les dimanches et conseils sur un
suivi de leur évolution et toutes ces
animations conférences ateliers sont
animés en partie être en partie par les
associations qui participent les
associations partenaires tels écarts
tels qu'american en vue tout à l'heure
vous lisez ce n'est pas la première fois
il ya des expérimentations auparavant
qui avait été menée sur le héros de zéro
déchet pardon avec une trentaine de
familles là on est passé un grand stade
ya plus de familles qui participent
cette année on a 5 90 familles
l'année dernière on a eu 2 112
c'était 700 personnes sensibilisées et
cette année vous voilà on à 190 ch oui
mais c'est là que le bilan est positif
chaque année c'est pour ça aussi con que
vous leur proposez oui il est très
positif les gens sont très motivés on
voit rapidement que les inscriptions
sont bons voilà les gens à s'inscrire
rapidement
c'est un sujet qui leur attire qui
s'adorent motive l'année dernière on a
eu 39 % de réduction des ordures
ménagères
mais pour parier
première phase où il pèse seulement
leurs déchets ensuite une seconde phase
où ils vont mettre en pratique les
différentes actions ce que ça veut dire
que vous les accompagner tout au long de
ce défi ces trois mois il ya différentes
actions peut être des réunions aussi
voilà il ya trois réunions principales
la réunion de lancement qui a été lieu
le 16 13 septembre pardon vendredi 13
ensuite il ya eu une réunion
intermédiaire on l'a on a fait une
espèce de forums des gestes pas
appliquée du coup il y avait différents
stands avec les différents gestes pour
réduire la poubelle il y aura une
rencontre des clôtures en janvier
pendant voilà faire un bilan
ça va être en forme à réparer zéro
déchet et ce jeudi alors il d une
conférence c'est peut-être lié aussi à
ce temps du défi zéro déchet une réunion
qui est ce jeudi au théâtre alphonse
daudet est à coignières la la thématique
télétel célibat la réduction des déchets
etc les serait trop longue réflexion sur
les impacts environnementaux et
sanitaires des déchets dans notre vie
quotidienne
et comment faire pour les réduire les
petites astuces pour les réduire
donc le lien entre gestion des déchets
et santé directs et environ aussi
environnement et c'est une conférence à
laquelle participent alinghi bris qui
est elle libre y aller ou brice et
tuncay
filles et là je pense qu'elle a 25 ans
et les consultants dans le développement
durable et économie circulaire et ça
fait cinq ans qu'on essaye de vivre de
faire de presque zéro déchet ça pouvait
le parent pèse 7 ordures ménagères elle
en train de refaire c'est 105 105
grammes que 105 grand et il a aidé
publié un livre en 2017 et y lire au
plastique et 0 toxique qui a 20 du pays
je pense qu'il a vendu plus de 15000
exemplaires et les six fondatrice un
bloc qui s'appelle consommant saignement
donc elle va venir partager son
expérience si on participe à ce défi
zéro déchet on peut quand même venir à
différents si c'est une conférence
ouverte à tout le monde et qui est au
programme donc ce jeudi à 19h au théâtre
alphonse daudet à coignières toutes les
informations à retrouver sur le site de
l'alec sky qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran merci maria dias baigneuses
d'être passé en plateau chargé de
mission énergie et animations à la lex
kayes et on aura l'occasion de re sud de
vous recevoir peut-être vous peut-être
quelqu'un d'autre de l'alec sky pour
faire un bilan à la fin de ce déficit
zéro déchet l'invitation est lancée
merci d'être peuvent passer en plateau
dans l'actualité également la
mobilisation lancé par les facteurs de
versailles depuis lundi il mène un
piquet de grève devant le centre de tri
de porchefontaine qui concerne aussi les
communes de but jouy en josas les loges
et viroflay aps lé postiers sont vent
debout contre la prochaine
réorganisation qui doit intervenir en
octobre des postes sont menacés
et il dénonce aussi une mauvaise
ambiance au sein de leur service et
demande le départ de leur direction
demandé le départ la direction locale à
l'origine de tous les problèmes il ya
une réorganisation à un gros plan de
suppression d'emplois où il y aura quand
même une hygiène de tournées de facteurs
qui vois-tu privé sur verfeil et les
communes alentours et les facteurs qui
devait justement rencontré leurs
directions cet après midi la grève qui
est reconduite pour demain mercredi 6 un
an après sa première édition l'entrée
d'un village revenait au domaine du mes
rentes et à magny les hameaux l'objectif
faire le point sur les dispositifs qui
permettent de soulager les aidants
marylène iapichino et patrick jacques de
dixmude
on recense 11 millions de personnes
aidantes en france elle assiste de façon
quotidienne un proche en perte
d'autonomie des situations difficiles
qui peuvent conduire l isolement pour
les soutenir l'institut une promotion de
la santé de saint quentin en yvelines
organisé son deuxième village entrée
dans ce village en fête a pour vocation
de faire découvrir des activités
ludiques de manière à proposer une pause
un peu dans le quotidien qui peut être
quelquefois un peu un peu lourd
ça permet aussi d'aller à la rencontre
de professionnels qui sont acteurs de
l'accompagnement du territoire ça permet
aussi de s'informer sur les aides
légales mais aussi les aides extra
légales qui existent et sur lesquels ils
peuvent prendre appui parmi les stands
le comptoir des aidants pour informer
conseiller ces derniers il ya plein
d'associations sur le territoire de la
ville nouvelle de saint quentin qui
oeuvre pour aider à la fois les
personnes et leurs proches
donc ça permet vraiment de découvrir
toute la palette de associatif qui peut
y avoir
un temps pour s'informer mais aussi un
temps pour soi
plusieurs ateliers étaient proposés pour
se détendre et passer un bon moment
je connais bien la maladie et ça aide ça
aide et à des moments de dépression
quand même c'est pour ça que moi je me
fais aider par tous ces trucs là une
rémunération pour le congé du projet
dans est en réflexion dans le projet de
loi de la sécurité sociale pour 2020
mais plus qu'un soutien financier cette
journée à l'entrée d'un village a rempli
son objectif de soutien moral à la
saison estivale s'est clôturé le 21
septembre dernier l'occasion pour le
département de dresser son étude
annuelle sur la fréquentation
touristique en été 2019 considéré comme
un bon cru dans la lignée de 2010 8 18%
des sites enregistrent une fréquentation
inhabituelle entre juin et août
année record par exemple pour le musée
d'archéologie nationale à saint germain
en laye qui enregistre une progression
de 22 24 % d'entrés elles meilleures
années depuis 50 ans c'est ce que dit la
direction du château de breteuil à
choisel plus + 16 % de fréquentation au
zoo de safari de thoiry stabilité enfin
du côté du château de versailles avec
plus de 3 millions de visiteurs
enregistré environ en revanche le bilan
est plutôt mitigé du côté des hôteliers
68% d'entre eux estiment que la saison a
été moyenne voire mauvaise au château de
versailles justement c'était samedi la
dictée pour tous étaient organisées par
les associations force de mixité et
nouvelles du vivre ensemble elle a été à
lui devant mille jeunes par maïtena
biraben et gad elmaleh le reportage de
patrick jacques de dixmude et de manon
varaldo
élèves de primaires collégiens lycéens
mais aussi adultes stylo en main testent
leur niveau d'orthographe
avec cette dictée pour tous le thème de
cette année la citoyenneté
il ya une vingtaine trentaine de jeunes
en situation d'handicap qui sont là ont
ils vont faire la dictée avec leurs
accompagnateurs avec leurs parents c'est
simple une dictée sur la citoyenneté
avec un public extrêmement divers et
variés c'est tout simplement ça le vivre
ensemble
karim buté sur la citoyenne
liberté égalité fraternité dans un
moment
meerson 60 personnes et ensemble
personnes s'est réunie devant je suis là
parce que maïtena biraben et gad elmaleh
ont eu cette dictée pour tous devant
mille jeunes venus parfois de loin sans
même
faire des blagues ma réaction à ces mots
là va être assez naturel il ya des mots
je veux pas les dévoiler tout de suite
mais il ya des mots qui prête à rire et
qui prête à la perplexité
parmi les pièges de cette dictée olic
idyllique ou encore le terme honni
coffrage à l'édifice
elle est difficile
on va apprécier allemand jeu personnel
parce que j'ai faits littéraires si je
fais des fautes là aurait vécu il ya des
mots que je ne connais pas donc
j'essaye d'appréhender composant un
petit peu leurs racines décide de
retrouver l'orthographe la dictée pour
tous créé par abdellah boudour a vu le
jour en 2013 sur la dalle d'argenteuil
237 dicter au compteur plus tard c'est
au château de versailles à la galerie
des batailles que le rendez vous a eu
lieu on a du mal avec la barrière de la
langue française d'orthographe est là
le fait qu'il ya de grandes
personnalités sa zone mazal une
symbolique basse affectueux
le mandat est venu il a vraiment un
engouement et j'espère que ces familles
là et ces associations de quartier ils
vont garder son se souvenir prochain
objectif faire cette dictée pour tous
dans un autre lieu emblématique à la
tour eiffel elle le sport et plus
précisément du cyclisme la présentation
du parcours officiel du tour de france
2020 était organisée ce mardi et le
peloton s'élancera une nouvelle fois
depuis les yvelines pour rejoindre l les
champs elysées lors de la dernière étape
bonsoir miquel et demi d'euros bonsoir
grégory journalistes aux sports la
rédaction tv 60,18 les yvelines ce n'est
pas une surprise en savez on ne savait
pas en revanche le lieu de cette
dernière étape quelle ville a été
choisie après où en 2018 et puis
rambouillet en 2019 les yvelines vont
accueillir pour la troisième année
consécutive la grande boucle cette année
c'est la ville de mantes la jolie qui a
été retenue pour recevoir l'événement le
19 juillet prochain
la dernière fois que la ville a vu
passer le tour c'était en 2014 lors de
l'étape amiens chartres on écoute la
réaction du directeur technique national
de la fédération française de cyclisme
christophe malin il ya une approche une
approche intégrée pour vous ni pour
arriver jusque dans paris mais mon plat
jolis souvenirs en 2018 qui a qui a été
belle réussite avec un joli joli
parcours qui avait fait la sélection
voilà moi je suis très heureux du choix
le montrent la jolie la jolie et donc
les yvelines ce n'est pas une surprise
mika n'ont pas vraiment à grégory
souvenez-vous le département des
yvelines et le groupe à essoyes
organisateurs du tour de france avait
signé en mars 2019 une convention pour
accueillir les dernières étapes du tour
de france jusqu'en 2023 seule la ville
de départ changera chaque année on
écoute
alexandre joly vice président délégué
aux sports il nous explique les raisons
de cette convention faut se souvenir que
2024 sera l'année des jeux olympiques et
que département accueillera le vélo mais
au-delà de ça le vélo dans les yvelines
c'est un bel os partage c'est un vélo
pour visiter c'est aussi un bel os santé
c'est un vélo pour tous puisque le
département à 850 km de voies cyclables
cette année près de vingt mille
personnes sont venues à rambouillet pour
voir le tour de france et le colombien
bernal en jaune
mantes-la-jolie espère faire faire mieux
voire faire aussi bien voire mieux on a
admis qu'elle est aussi découvrir le
parcours complet de cette dernière étape
qui partira donc de mantes la jolie
merci pour ces précisions ce week-end
prenait fin également la fête de la
science saint-quentin-en-yvelines
proposé pour l'occasion un village des
sciences du vendredi au dimanche à la
commanderie à elancourt marylène
iapichino et mélanie poquet l'on exploré
ils ont la tête dans les étoiles
dans ce cas c'est la réalité virtuelle
se balade dans le ciel de la nuit
précédente
on et comment la cosmonaute tourner dans
l'espace
ça c'est impressionnant ça c'est
dérouleront ce planétarium est l'une des
animations proposées au sein de ce
village des sciences installé durant
trois jours à la commanderie à elancourt
c'est l'occasion de faire découvrir aux
gens un ciel qui voit plus en fait dans
les villes et c'est l'occasion aussi
pour les jeunes de leur donner envie
faire la science depuis 12 ans
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines rassemble laboratoire
entreprises universités et associations
pour présenter la science à un large
public
chaque stand l'a finalement un double
discours à la fois pour un public
familial en médiation scientifique
on doit savoir s'adapter à tout public
donc faire une proposition qu'on dit
vulgariser pour les plus jeunes est bas
plus approfondie pour les adultes en
famille les visiteurs pouvaient
notamment joué les apprentis chimistes
ou observer le soleil à l'aide de cet
appareil qui filtrent la lumière mais a
l'habitude de voir où d'entendre les
astronomes qui parle des étoiles mais
c'est vrai qu'on a plus rarement
l'occasion de voir la note le soleil et
ewen les gens sont assez curieux en
général les tableau périodique ont pris
place dans la salle des gardes les
mesures était le thème départemental de
la fête de la science
on apprend plein de choses même à nos
grands agents
garder des biens
coopté
j'ai regardé aussi des pierres j'ai fait
de la science et j'ai tapé sur le clou
dressé plus grandement certaine mais
c'est intéressant
plus d'un millier de personnes ont
profité de ce village pour toucher la
science du bout des doigts à montigny le
bretonneux l'exposition de modélisme
multidisciplinaire s'est tenu le
week-end dernier à la ferme du manège
sur place des stands de bateaux de train
des circuits de voitures des bassins est
des associations venues de toute l'île
de france à l'invitation des amis à des
flots et des passionnés des trains et
deux jours d'événements pendant
lesquelles sont venus 4500 visiteurs
grâce notamment un changement lieu pour
cette édition mélanie poké pour les
interviews
devant le succès qu'on avait rencontré
il ya deux ans en mars 2018 dans tout
nous a poussés à faire
plus grand nous avons réussi à avoir une
salle est quatre fois plus important
donc ça nous a permis de faire venir
d'autres associations et de d'augmenter
notre
présentation et pour le public quand on
a vu le succès qui en avait dans une
autre salle de montigny 1800 et quelques
entrées j'ai dit aux deux présidents
celui du train et des bateaux dits côté
il faut vraiment qu'on essaye de monter
une exposition sur une autre dimension
et donc pourquoi pas le faire à la ferme
human est un événement qui fait
frétiller les papilles le salon du
chocolat se déroulera du 30 octobre au 3
novembre à paris une robe en chocolat il
sera présenté l'oeuvre d'une rencontre
entre artisans la reine astrid implantés
notamment dans les yvelines et deux
autres maisons qui ont décidé de s'unir
pour cette création et qui mêlent
broderies chocolat et et broderies je l'
ai déjà dit marylène iapichino ac est
glissée dans l'atelier pour cette
préparation au fond de cet atelier à
savigny-sur-orge quatre artisans se
concentre sur une surprenante création
au liban
ça marche beaucoup mieux
c'est tout
l'atelier flore et brice et pour la
broderie les deux frères de l'atelier
terry pour la dorure et la chocolaterie
à la reine astrid pour le chocolat ce
trio de maisons d'artisanat s'est unie
pour créer une robe en chocolat qui
défilera au 25e salon du chocolat de
paris à la base flore hybris est
designer textile
c'est elle qui a imaginé et fabriqué la
structure de la mort en général la
broderie pour le trail de dorure à la
feuille sont les éléments décoratifs qui
sont ajoutés par dessus le vêtement ou
l'élément décoratif ici c'est ce travail
là qui est mis en avant en
l'aimant structurelle d'une certaine
manière le plastron en plastique et donc
brodé il a nécessité 80 des heures de
travail avant de pouvoir être recouverts
de chocolat nicolas morin s'occupe du
chocolat pour s'assurer qu'il se
maintienne
il applique une couche de vernis puis du
chocolat brut
une deuxième couche de vernis et termine
avec de la poudre de cacao pour donner
une texture à la robe pour le chocolat
il faut qu'il soit quand même assez fin
finalement parce que s'il est trop épais
et si on applique de manière trop
épaisse est-ce que de se passer que avec
son propre poids
et avec les mouvements qu'il y aura du
coup
au moment du défilé ça se décolle pour
mettre en valeur le travail de broderie
les frères thierry s'occupe de la dorure
en savoir faire familial sont maintenant
depuis dix ans tous les deux et notre
sort nous a rejoint tout récemment
tous deux se relaient pour appliquer la
colle puis déposez les feuilles d'or un
matériau très fins qui ne peut être pris
à la main et nécessitent l'utilisation
d'une palette en poils de martre s'est
passé pratique quand on met ça c'est
pour graisser un peu la palette où on
peut la placer sur les cheveux ou pour
un petit peu d'électricité statique ou
lvc un peu et si pour pouvoir attraper
la feuille relativement facilement au
but et viendra s'ajouter une jupe drapée
tout en souplesse et les doreurs
ornements trop la peau d'elizabeth
tchoungui la journaliste franco
camerounaise choisi pour porter la robe
ça fait longtemps que j'ai envie de
faire défiler une robe un salon du
chocolat est en fait mon engagement au
cameroun depuis quelques années fait que
tout naturellement s'est dit que ça
serait sympa de faire un truc qui tourne
aussi autour du cameroun
la robe défilera au milieu de 22 autres
lors de la soirée inaugurale du salon du
chocolat le 29 octobre
quant à la chocolaterie de la reine
astrid vous pouvez la retrouver tout le
long du salon stand des 42 c'est la fin
de ce journal demain mercredi vous nous
retrouverez depuis l'université des
mairies au port marly pour une série
d'émissions en direct et c'est à
retrouver toute la journée
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]